as you can imagine with everything
that's unfolded since the senseless
killing of George Floyd we're
approaching the show very differently
this week I had a great conversation
earlier today with W kamau Bell someone
I really respect and I'd like to get
right to that so without further ado
here's my conversation with W kamau Bell
with what's been going on in the streets
of our nation over the past week I
wanted to have a one-on-one conversation
with a friend of our show who's not only
a comedian but a longtime advocate for
racial justice he's the celebrity
ambassador on racial justice for the
ACLU and he sits on the advisory boards
of organizations like DonorsChoose which
raises money for public schools and
hollaback an anti harassment
organization please welcome the host of
CNN's Emmy Award winning United States
of America w kamau Bell how are you
doing
you know everybody asked that question
my family's healthy we're fine but we're
also getting feral it would stand at
home and not going to school and stuff
yeah yeah well obviously I wanted to
start we did a show on Monday and I
talked to Van Jones and I very much
wanted to make that about listening but
clearly that's maybe for me the first
step and there is now so much more to be
done which is I think a lot of us are
feeling I protests are fine but what can
we do and when I say we I mean all of us
and people like myself what can we do to
make this situation better in a
practical pragmatic way well I mean I
think the I would you know I would let
me clear that wouldn't you say we let's
be clear that I feel like you're saying
white people as when we because I feel
like black people brown people people of
color we have always done this work and
we've always had to figure out what to
do in situations where we had very
little I mean if you imagine Conan I
know it's gonna be it's gonna be hard to
imagine
to being harriet tubman you know they're
saying like I do that all the time I
know you were up for the movie missed it
by that much that much Harriet Tubman
wasn't enslaved African who had no
resources at all and had to imagine what
can I do and you know and now she's in a
rightfully so an American Hero because
in that moment she just got to work and
so I think black people especially black
people have always had to figure out
what to do so I really put it on white
people to go what do you see that you
want to do I think a lot of times white
people get caught up in like being
scared of doing it wrong and I'm like
yes be confident you're gonna do it
wrong that's how the work gets done you
know MLK and his first move wasn't the
march on Washington they did a lot of
things to prepare for that you're gonna
get it wrong white people get used to
doing it wrong
you're gonna get do something you feel
good about and then somebody's gonna
call you out for doing it the wrong way
and you're gonna have to get used to
sitting in the space of like not doing
the work right but right now a lot of
white people are frozen by the I don't
know what to do so I'll do nothing and
that's why black people get get
brutalized by police officers over and
over again because white people go all
that was so bad I feel so bad but then a
couple weeks later back to my yoga
classes and right now right there's not
going back to yoga classes because
there's a global pandemic right now
right there is a sense that right now
protests are very visual this is anyway
how I'm feeling that you see a lot of
people and you especially you see a lot
of celebrities being very visual about
their protesting and then the concern I
would think and rightfully so would be
this is fine maybe in this moment to be
visual and to be on the front lines but
how are you gonna follow up on this 3 6
9 weeks from now next year the year
after that to make America what it
should be well I think that's that's the
important point because even if you
Conan O'Brien go out to a protest you're
gonna get a lot of attention people
gonna feel that that image is going to
go viral all over the world
world you know people are gonna notice
it but then black folks are always like
what's Conan doing in his life right and
I think it I think right now it's very
important to connect your life to the
actual movement into the actual making
change because believe me if you if you
said black Americans here's what I'm
gonna do I'm going to do a complete
internal audit of my show I'm gonna ask
TBS do the same thing of where the black
folks work at TBS where other people of
color work and not give you the
percentage of the total but go at what
level they are at how many your people
are the top level how many people are at
the at the lowest levels the TBS in my
show and I'm gonna tell you that and
then in a year it's gonna look different
and I'm gonna show you what that looks
like I'm gonna tell you about my
personal like in my personal life how
many black people I interact with in my
day and in a year I'm gonna work hard to
make that look better and I'm gonna
write now we need white people to show
their work you know it's not enough to
say I'm gonna read Michelle Alexander's
book it's enough to go I read it and
here are my thoughts
it doesn't anybody have thoughts about
my thoughts I think right now a lot of
white people it's easy to sort of like
change your Twitter a V to a black
background or to black lives matter but
eventually you're gonna turn it back to
that wacky picture you know that I mean
so we need white people to not only do
the work but show their work because we
can't trust that the works may get done
because all these articles are written
blogs are written the government's done
studies the Kerner commission was a
study that said white supremacy is the
rule of the land and this is why these
things are happening but the work
doesn't get done we need white people to
show their work right now the something
that's occurred to me and I'm sure
occurred to a lot of people but money in
our society is a very powerful an engine
maybe the most powerful engine where it
goes how it's used and it it yes there's
a lot of rhetoric and the rhetoric is
very important but sometimes you think
we're how am i how am i helping black
owned businesses how am i employing
people of color what are we doing to
make sure that student debt student loan
and the price of education isn't leaving
out a huge
version of society from getting an
education what are the practical things
we can do now that lasts mm-hmm I mean
there's there's two different there's
two different things there's what can
you do that lasts but also what can you
do right now
there's the the houses on fire put out
the fire and then there's like rebuild
the house so I don't want people to get
caught up in like I can give fifty
dollars here but what can I do give the
money you have now to support the causes
and I'm happy to send you some causes
your way if you don't know what these
are but then again it's really about how
you are in your personal life because if
your personal life is correct your
public life usually is more correct if
you are personally invested in this if
you're personally like you know what we
don't have enough black people on this
show in high positions so I'm gonna make
sure we go out and find those people and
I'm gonna put out a call for this where
I don't have enough I don't have enough
black people in my personal life that
I'm employing or you're taking we are
taking advice from I'm gonna change that
it's to me it's like a lot of this is
focused on outside and it really focus
on inside because black people we don't
do this work for black people we do it
for ourselves and one thing white people
need to get is that fight fighting white
supremacy being an anti-racist should be
a selfish act because if the world is
more equitable and just for black people
and people of color it's automatically
better for white people
it just doesn't it's it's it this is
truly the rising tide that lifts all
both but right but I think a lot of
times white people feel like I'm doing
it for them I did this for them I'm done
with I'm doing for them and that's why
it doesn't the work isn't lasting right
I I think especially anybody who has
children knows your children and and
this is for any anybody I mean I think
about this a lot I want it to be a
fairer world because a fairer and more
just world is a safer world for my kids
so that is a way to see it in if in a
very selfish way but a very primal way
if you're a parent who loves your child
I want my child to be walking around
streets where the other people walking
those Street streets feel that they have
a stake in society because then my child
safer
they're living in a happier world so
this is not a bad thing selfishness is
very natural and it feels to me that
that's I think I think it is I think it
I think
describing it selfishness not those two
it's helpful to people can stop thinking
like I'm doing it because I'm a good
person as you just said a world that is
more just and equitable is better for
your kids it's a safer world but it's
also a more fun world the best music
festivals are the one that have all the
music there because it's like it's we
get to hang out with everybody it's like
it's not it's not just a more like it's
not again we get caught up in the high
mindedness of this get caught up in the
humanity of it get caught up in the fact
that it's just a it's a more your
children will be more so more actualized
they'll have more freedom of expression
they'll take in more information I mean
one of the best things about being a
parent is getting your kids to not just
eat peanut butter jelly sandwiches
because that's not a good life that's
not a that's not a life that leads you
down a good direction it's about we're
at the parents are actively expanding
our kids palates but you have to do the
same thing with your kids brained
and I'd say I encourage you I don't know
how old your kids are I'll do kids I
have my son is 14 and my daughter is 16
okay I mean I think it's important to
know what they're reading it's important
to put both those kids could put you
could put the autobiography of malcolm x
right in their hands today and they're
ready for it you know I think it's
important to know to encourage them to
not just read the things they want to
read or being assigned but really reach
out to other sources that both those
kids can Ratana he see Coates but then
you should read it too and then talk to
them about it but with my kids with
parents of little kids don't get books
that it feature more diverse images I'm
a big fan of Mo Willems big fan of
Sandra Boynton but also big fan of
Selena Alko and big fan of doc
McStuffins and other things that
actually reflect the world that I want
that that my kids can see themselves in
there's a lot of talk in the last two
three days about black lives matter and
then peeps on people saying well all
lives matter and then
people getting very angry and saying you
don't understand what you're saying when
you say all lives matter even though if
you take that situation in an or that
sentence in and of itself out of context
yes you don't disagree with it but when
you look at it in the context that's
very upsetting to people and I'd like to
talk about that or hear what you have to
think say about it I mean the phrase
black lives matter is intentionally
provocative it was a phrase that was
created by three black women opal tometi
alicia garza and patrisse cullors in the
wake of the Trayvon Martin murder by
George Zimmerman and it was a
declaration of like we need people to
know black lives matter because at that
time and still it does not feel like
black lives matter the criminal justice
system does not put a value on black
lives this education system is I've put
a value on black lives so obviously
we're talking about the police please
don't put a value on black lives so that
it's an intentionally provocative phrase
and here's why because Martin Luther
King's let's hug it out didn't work
Martin Luther King jr. was talking about
hey everybody basically can't we be
friends
Rodney King's let's all just get along
didn't work so so black people keep
raising the stakes on getting the
attention of white people you know NWA
had a very effective we're gonna raise
the stakes for to get the attention of
of black people I'm not gonna say it on
TBS but Google it it so yeah right black
people's are basically doing all we can
to get white people's attention
understand how clear this is so if
you're bothered by the phrase black
lives matter
good now investigate the phrase because
the fact is all lives don't matter the
same if they did we wouldn't have to say
black lives matter and nobody this is
why if you use the phrase all lives
matter it is just an attack on the idea
of black lives matter and this is how I
sit and to say that nobody ever said all
lives matter before the phrase black
lives matter right it was only invented
in the wake of black lives matter
nobody was wrong on going I just want to
say all lives matter nobody said that if
somebody had said that you said are you
ok do you need to eat
- sugar you need some sugar in school
carbs right yeah like that that line is
like even the Beatles who are full of
love never decided to say that it's just
not it doesn't have any meaning to it so
for me it's like if you understand that
you get there white people but once you
get there understand why we're not there
and I think to me I would challenge
people who like it we do understand that
claim that you know put that sign up in
your front yard put it in your window
don't just put it on your social media
make your neighbors see it but have
conversations with your community
because this is the thing we need white
people to talk to each other about this
there's great organizations out there
surge showing up for racial justice
which is a white LED racial justice
organization where white people meet
with each other cuz a lot of times you
need to have these awkward conversations
with each other when you're not afraid
of what black folks are gonna say her
over here so white people need to do
this work actually right now Conan I'm
going to assign you a friend of mine to
be in charge of your whiteness no okay
all right
here we go I want my assignment I really
do I didn't come here just to talk I'm
giving you homework so give your kids
autobiography of malcolm x you read it
too if you haven't read it it's not you
can't just watch the movie the movies
great but read the autobiography malcolm
x and a friend of mine named Kate shots
who's a white woman who wrote the book
rad American women a to z is deals with
white people all the time about how to
deal with this work so Kate shots he's
on Twitter I'll hook you guys up later
is now in charge of Conan O'Brien's
whiteness okay well and also I'm not
just white I am so white that that's a
putting someone in charge of my
whiteness is this she may decline she
made
that's too much whiteness for me to
handle believe me you've got enough
public stuff out there she's familiar
with who you are we are I just called
her before this to say are you good with
being a chargin Conan O'Brien's white
this is she was like who she deceived
she took at me and she took some deep
breaths
but she and she played she wrote that
she did some math and she's like I think
I can do this let me play
that's like saying can you bench press
do you think you can get to 800 pounds
exactly she's like let me clear my
schedule she's clear she's cleared her
schedule of all other whiteness to be a
child Hey well
I literally just got the phone with her
all right well tell her she's gonna
probably we're gonna have to live
together she's gonna explain this is a
24/7 job being here you know I I also
I'm curious about this phenomenon I
talked about it a bit with its Van Jones
and it's something that I'm trying to
explore which is how exhausting it is
for black people to be explaining their
lives in their situation to concerned
white liberal white people and how
there's a fatigue that comes with that
mm-hmm which is please tell us you know
every three months or two months or one
month when something awful happens it's
now become it's incumbent on you to
explain to me what's going on when that
clearly should not why is it suddenly
your homework it's not your homework
well I will say that I think that's I
accepted as part of my job like this is
the I basically get paid to do this work
so I accept it but the black guy at work
who makes less money than you who you're
like I just need to talk to you about
this he's not being paid for it I feel
like a big part of reparations would
just be a government stipend to give
black people 50% more salary just to
deal with white people when racist
things happen in the news like that
would be I would agree to that
reparations no but it but also that I
mean it's it's it's free what I love
others so what I love about your
approach is you're your comedian you're
very funny so you come up with these
comedic ideas which are funny but also
true and you think about anything no
that actually would make sense if there
was a stipend for how much now I have to
spend six more hours of my week
explaining racism to concerned white
people so I should get $7,000 those
should be billable hours it's like yeah
exactly and I think and I think white
people don't realize that because you
come to us like I'm finally ready to
have the conversation that you've wanted
me to have
and that person's like I'm trying to eat
lunch for 15 minutes and get back to my
job and if we say we don't want to have
it then you're mad at see this is why we
can't end racism because of you because
you won't talk to me
right and it's like and all of this is
work and it and it's work and America
has a history of not paying for the
labor that black folks do and this is
just a part of that yeah the you know I
think I keep trying to find some notes
of hope in all of this
I'm really hoping there are some as
horrifying and terrible as that video of
George Floyd being killed is there was
no way not to see it if you're a white
American and not immediately no that
would never happen to me that would not
happen to me I would never be in that
situation that I would be treated
differently and I'm not even just
talking about someone who's on
television no if I was Conan O'Brien and
I was a spot welder who'd no one had
ever heard of that would never ever
happen to me and III I
I think that is one of the reasons why
somehow this feels so seismic yes there
have been many of these situations many
of these videos but I I'm hoping that
this one and I could be wrong you can
tell me I'm wrong right now I'm hoping
this one is getting us is moving the
puzzle piece a little more is that am I
wrong am I wrong to be hopeful I think
it's an opportunity for that I I think I
asked me if I'm hopeful all time I'm
only hopeful as long as I keep doing the
work so I think a lot of times people
feel hope like something will happen
like you know cops kneeling with
protesters people are like oh it's gonna
get better because cops met with
protesters but in actuality a lot of
those same cops or cops in those police
departments are also the cops who are
pepper spray people who are shooting
rubber bullets the people in Kansas City
the some of the
cops melt with protesters and the mayor
net with coke protesters and then I
think it was the same day but within 24
hours cops ran up on a black man who was
just screaming at them and using his his
freedom of speech and pepper sprayed him
right in the face and the people around
them and then dragged him out and all
wrestled him to the ground in Kansas
City Missouri both those things happen
in Kansas City so I think if you're
looking for hope
look for it in work don't look forward
to images or moments and I think the
other thing I would say about that the
way you feel the way that a lot of white
people and you're saying you feel about
what you saw with George Florida a lot
of black people have felt that
repeatedly right I mean I look at Eric
garner was the one for me that made me
just like I mean it was a I mean a lot
of it was he was a six foot four
250-pound black guy that's my bit much
my description he had asthma
that's my description when he was saying
I can't breathe I know a lot of that was
because as an asthmatic you your lungs
fail quicker and I was like I felt that
feeling of not being able to breathe and
people called him a gentle giant that's
been written about me so I I feel
horrible about George Floyd and I felt
horrible before and a lot of bike you
got horrible for the thing that makes
this moment different cone and I want to
be clear about this white people had
more access to it because we're in the
middle of a global pandemic and more of
a sir at home watching the news so it's
not a I don't think it's about that
specifically it's about the fact that
maybe before the new clip of the black
person being killed by cops would come
across your desk and you just want to
push it push it aside or you will watch
it once but if you're watching the news
you're seeing it over and over again
because of the fact our country at the
top level has failed with dealing with
the corona virus pandemic so we're all
at home watching the news that's uh I
have nothing to say to that other than
you were you are a hundred percent
correct
I really I really do believe that that
you're right that we all of us had to
sit and see that image over and over and
over again and that is a situation
that's just the situation we're in
because of CO vid 19 but it's
it's too bad it's it's a shame that it
took that for people to really pay
attention I can I ask you a question
Conan yeah do you accept or believe that
this country is run by white supremacy I
believe that
complicated I don't believe that that is
the aim of everybody in this country I
don't I'm not talking about like the aim
of each individual white people you know
I married a white person so I'm not here
to be the anti white person I'm just
talking about the fort that this country
there is a there is forces in place that
are institutional and structural that
just sort of that promote whiteness over
the over other race yes oh yes
definitely I I definitely believe that
that is inherent in the the mission
statement of this country historically
and that it is a I talked about this on
Monday that it has been a long horrible
history of us and and people focus so
much on slavery but it goes so much
beyond that and I'll also say it's not
just the United States of America it's
it's a global problem I think racism is
is built in too many structures around
the world I believe that in my heart and
I think that the history of this country
is these spasms of trying to confront it
and trying to improve it and we have
these moments where I think people and
I'm gonna say be specific where I think
white people can feel like we did it we
got there this the second the first
election of Barack Obama and then the
second one had us feeling in a naive
sense we did it we're there we're not
there do you know where we're far from
there I don't even know what there is
I don't we may never completely be there
because it's it's like doing I like
analogies cuz my brain works but when
you're working out or taking care of
your body you're never there it is it's
like what you're talking about you got
to do the work you don't finish doing
sit-ups and say I'm done I'm there it is
a and I'm this is coming from someone
who does not do sit-ups let me make that
really clear
it is this is the work that doesn't end
it does not end so I do think there are
moments I grew up in a very I I grew up
in Boston so it's a it's a it's a city
with a terrible racist history and
racial past and still confronts racial
problems but I grew up in a very liberal
public school system in the 70s where
you know people are wearing dashikis and
I I grew up with black friends and I
really did think racism of is a thing of
the past
and this is in the 1970s I really
believed that we had and and this is
only ten years after the the worst of
the civil rights struggles I believed
that as a child like well at least I
think we took care of racism that's
because I was living in a little bubble
and I was a kid and was all I've been my
whole life since then and I'm now 57
years old has been learning over and
over and over again
that there's so much to be done there's
so much work to do and being filled with
optimism and then despair so that's the
cycle and and yes I think that America
is a work in progress
is has been my motto it is he still a
young country and it's a country that
has a lot of work to do I mean III hear
what you're saying I think that some
people I think some people there's I've
seen a meme going around some people
saying the system isn't broken the
system was designed to do this and I
think that's what so that's what a lot
of black you will feel like is like this
is actually since black people were
freed from enslavement the system has
worked hard to keep us as close to that
as possible through not giving not
giving us access to the vote through not
giving our not giving it allowing us to
have the same access to a good education
as white folks do incarcerate more
people than the rest of the world does
and more those people are black and
proportionally should be so the system
has designed to do this so even the fact
that the election of Barack Obama the
system
response was Donald Trump yes and that
happens through not just like because
Trump is a bloviating sort of like
soundbite machine and people like that
it's because through gerrymandered
districts through the electoral college
not valuing the popular vote the system
has controls in place for things to be
more inclusive and more equitable and I
got through I mean when I say white
supremacy because it's like I think a
lot of times white people get caught up
in white supremacists and white
supremacy a white supremacist is the Ku
Klux Klan we don't even need to really
be worried about them for the most part
they are at they are the mascots of
white supremacy right white supremacy
premise II is 44 out of 45 American
presidents being white men that's the
system that is that has you think they
just those happen to be the it just
having 4000 white men just happen to be
the best presidents that's the system
putting things in place like we can't
get access to the to the Ivy League
inner circle conversations that white
that white people can so we don't have
the groups we don't have people we don't
have the wealth around us to fun to race
for presidency and we don't have those
sort of like just social circles where
we would wind up in places where
somebody be like you should run for
president and here's on how we're gonna
make it happen that's the that's the
system of white supremacy that is and I
think white people need to be very clear
about that that's a lot of times white
people will come very comfortable I
don't like that how who did that bad
thing but the system means that if you
become a cop you adopt racism or your or
you either adopt it or you ignore it cuz
that's the other part a lot of good cops
but there's a lot of quote-unquote good
cops watching bad cops do that and not
stepping up and not stopping it there
was four cops that could have stepped up
and said stop this who didn't and and
who may or may not be by the time this
airs maybe they've been arrested or
charged but they didn't do anything if
that they would have been heroes if any
one of them had stepped up but cops
don't do that it's the system of white
supremacy that that encourages cops not
just not to speak out against other cops
yeah I think the when you bring up white
supremacy obviously people go right to
neo-nazi fascism
they they go to an extreme rather than
understanding that yes anyone who says
the skids haven't been greased for white
people in this country is [ __ ] so
absolutely absolutely agree with that
belief and they did Greece did both
directions they've been greased for you
to go up and they've been greased for
black people to not be able to get any
traction on the way up so I think that's
the it's both an and I think that's the
thing we want to get to is that it's
both and I think a lot of times again
it's the same thing you're saying about
working out if you want to feel good
about your body and you don't work at
that often you look at somebody who
works out less than you you don't look
at the look at the you don't look at a
photo of Bruce Lee you can you look at
somebody right and so I think a lot of
times white people like to sort of like
to central centers the neo-nazi the Ku
Klux Klan the alright going I'm not as
bad as that so I'm a good person instead
of looking at white people like my
friend and Kate shots or Jane Elliott or
all these are all these other white
people are out there who are on the
front lines of the work and who are
invested in being able to say white
supremacist rule of the land as a white
person my voice is more valuable in
dismantling that system because of white
supremacy than a black person's a couple
of things I want to make sure that we
get the word out on the causes that you
think are are really gonna help and make
a difference and a practical difference
so that people can be throwing buckets
of water on the fire now and so I want
to make sure that we post those and we
put those out on our social media I also
want to do everything I can
my my my education as a white man
someone whose I love my make sure that
this person who's taking care of me and
is taking on my white hey Kate I want to
make sure that Kate shots I want to make
sure that she's promoted and yes but
it's not just my education because God
knows there's a lot to be done but that
it's everybody's education so absolutely
make sure we do that is there anything
you wanted to say before we we we end
this for tonight no I think it's it's
really
important to I first off thank you for
having me on the show honored to have
you always honored to have you yeah yes
I appreciate the fact that that you're
having these conversations and other
late-night show hosts are doing this at
this time and it's personally somebody
who's not I've seen you speak out before
and you've inspired me before we've
spoken out you know whether this airs or
not how you left the Tonight Show and
what you said about snark and being mean
really has stayed with me oh good okay
and it really helped get it helped me
get through a hard part of my career so
you specifically have helped me well so
I appreciate you doing this right now I
love that you came on the show today and
we need to make this a regular gig I
know you've been on we've talked many
times before but we need to keep it
going we need to keep it going and and
then and you're really it's on top of
everything else you're a very funny man
and I think and I believe that that's a
superpower that is a beautiful thing
especially in times of real sadness and
tragedy and you have that superpower and
I'm so I'm just I'm great I'm very
grateful to you in so many ways
Thank You Conan and thank you for using
you know the word platform is overused
but it's really important to use your
platform and like I would just encourage
you to show your show your work you know
have these conversations but also show
the changes that come from it will
happen it will happen well that is our
that is our night that is our I think
we've this is the longest I've ever
spoken to anybody on any show and you
know what I just absolutely loved it
this is so thank you so much and we will
get the word out and I will do the work
and let's all do the work thank you
thank you are you sir all right I would
do that back at you but I'm not sure I'm
supposed to well Kate we'll build you up
to that I'll let Kate handle that if
you'd like more information on some of
the causes w Kamau supports here are
ones that will help put the fire out now
live free USA or
which provides mass for the black and
Hispanic people hardest hit by kovat 19
DonorsChoose which is helping
disadvantaged children with distance
learning and to rebuild the house black
to the future org which works to enact
policies that improve the lives of black
people and you can follow the person in
charge of my whiteness Kate Schatz at at
Kate Schatz she's the author of the rad
American women series and man has her
work cut out for her you can see wkl
bells United shades of America with W
kamau Bell when it returns for its fifth
season later this month on CNN good
night